you can never do enough when it comes to  Mental Health and Wellness  [Music]  digitization of our workplaces from  covid is the fact that we're seeing huge  numbers in stresses at work we have  burnout we have stress we've increased  levels of anxiety depression  fatigue brain fog we have now a mobile  office at all times in our hand is  extremely difficult because how do you  disconnect  the economic impact the societal impact  that we have with mental health if we do  not address it now when we're at these  Crossroads of great change and bringing  our EU together it's not this generation  that will feel the suffer and suffer  from it it's going to be the future  Generations  we're calling for a psychosocial  directive further work on the right to  disconnect you can never do enough best  practices signposting working on really  Progressive legislation so we are  creating and becoming the gold standard  when it comes to mental health and  wellness here in the European Union  foreign